mother's day is fast approaching and our
next guest has the perfect
tech gift for that special lady in your
life
let's welcome back tech expert sarah
evans sarah this first
fitness gift is something i love and i
know my mom will love as well what is it
it's called the loop fitness band i
actually wear it and i'm a happy
customer and it's something if you have
a fit mom in your life
this tracks 24 7 recovery strain
and sleep metrics so you can help your
mom perform better
make sure she's getting enough rest it
also allows you to join a community or
live record your fitness routine so you
can send to coaches to get feedback
um so there are many other implications
for it plus you know it's fun
fashionable and no notifications so
she's not getting interrupted it looks
really cool it's very stylish as well
this next one is ai robot vacuum tell me
more about it
okay i'm gonna be honest i was hesitant
about this but the folks from trifo
sent me lucy and she's been running in
my house for the past 48 hours
and i've never felt cleaner so it is an
ai powered robot vacuum that you can
control with an app and it gets smarter
every time you use it
it has things like obstacle avoidance so
if your kids are dropping toys or cords
or socks on the ground
you can set up schedules so i've had it
go off at night time when we're asleep
where we cannot hear it
also has motion detection so if you have
little ones you're worried about running
around during the day during nap time or
at night it'll alert you if someone runs
by the vacuum
and i love the name too that's lucy my
my vacuum what's the next item you have
for us
so books subscription think freshly
delivered flowers but tech you can go to
the booth's website and set up
a schedule for the mom in your life
weekly
bi-weekly monthly and have fresh flowers
delivered
to the home it starts as low as 36
dollars it can go up to 60 dollars and
higher per month and yes you can skip if
someone's not going to be home and be on
vacation
but what a great year-long gift it's a
gift that keeps on giving and giving and
giving
this last one i think every mom everyone
will actually love this next gift what
is it
cameo is one of my favorite services you
can go to it and find celebrities to
record personalized messages for the
loved ones in your life
thinking about your mom you can pay them
give them some personal information and
they'll record something
specifically unique to whoever it is
you're creating for it's really special
it's timeless you get a copy of the
video
she can post it on social media and show
how loved she is not only by her own
children but by celebrities
and every celebrity is on there it's
awesome thank you so much sarah and
happy mother's day to you
las vegas